E aí
é bom gente eu não preciso nem dizer o
tamanho da minha alegria está aqui e
principalmente depois do que eu passei
então certamente está aqui tem um
significado muito maior a sato's um ano
atrás eu estava aqui falando projeto
sete cumes que consiste em instalar da
maior montanha de cada continente que
nós já vimos executados seis etapas com
pleno sucesso em Abril e maio desse ano
estaremos concluindo com a escalada do
Everest e dia 29 de março 2013 deste ano
partir para o Nepal para concluir esse
projeto e depois de 15 dias na montanha
passei para a maior tragédia da história
do Everest nós estamos falando da maior
montanha da terra a montanha tem o maior
número de fatalidades
o e infelizmente quando a gente tava se
preparando para escalada na parte mais
difícil ver uma avalanche vocês viram
sair foram as primeiras notícias que
apareceram na imprensa ainda estavam
quentinhos falando de 12 pessoas na
verdade esse ano a temporada matou 19
pessoas é só nessa avalanche morreram 16
pessoas e infelizmente Além desse número
ser muito grande três deles eram colegas
meus e no dia anterior na verdade 15
horas antes nós estávamos fazendo uma
solenidade comemorando cantando todo
mundo se preparando para uma grande
conquista para um realizar um grande
sonho que A Escalada do Everest E aí
Enquanto estávamos todos feliz e
contente nos preparando para isso nós
vemos uma tragédia para a gente ter uma
ideia da dimensão do Agreste em Duas
Faces É algumas pessoas ficavam pelo
lado Tibete e China outros Calam pelo
lado Nepal Você tem uma ideia são várias
vezes
e por ano a mortalidade ainda é número 6
pessoas nos últimos 11 anos havia
morrido exato 66 pessoas ou seja durante
um ano seis pessoas nós tivemos em um
minuto 16 mortos e não foi fácil estar
no meio daquele furacão ver os meus
colegas que no dia anterior Estamos
fazendo vídeos fotografando é todos
comemorando e agora não passavam naquele
momento não passavam de Corpos
congelados o helicóptero resgatando
esses corpos e trazendo enfim foi um
furacão muito pesado a princípio para a
maioria das pessoas que estavam Everest
foi uma tragédia imensa principalmente
porque achava que tinha gastado um mundo
de dinheiro para realizar uma expedição
ao Everest e o sonho não foi realizado
por um lado talvez esteja até uma
verdade para mim não eu consegui ver um
outro lado da moeda
é a vida tem dessas coisas a gente não
pode desistir por nada dos nossos sonhos
eu costumo dizer que até negocio prazo o
sonho não eu abraço meus sonhos sempre e
não desiste de nada que eu quero na vida
mesmo sabendo que isso não é fácil mas a
gente precisa ter essa flexibilidade
para saber que nem sempre as coisas
acontecem quando a gente quer e o maior
lucro que eu tive nessa expedição gente
põe o convívio com chapas é uma cultura
tão diversa da nossa é um povo tão
diferente para vocês terem uma ideia 99
porcento da população do Nepal estão
entre budistas e hinduístas ambos
acreditam em reencarnação para gente ter
uma noção de padrão de vida dessas
pessoas enquanto um canadense e tem um
patamar que é uma renda per capita anual
acima de 30 mil dólares os nepaleses
estão abaixo de $700 ano então é um povo
materialmente falando muito pobre mas
muito pobre
e eu confesso para vocês que eu nunca vi
um povo tão rico tão rico que no momento
aquela avalanche Quando aconteceu aquela
tragédia daquela Dimensão em nenhum
momento eu parei para pensar quando eu
tinha trabalhado para juntar dinheiro
para me preparar para chegar no fundo
Everest naquele momento o meu foco era
está conservas era dividir com eles um
sofrimento que não é fácil e orar os
meus colegas que perderam irmãos era pai
que perdeu o filho era filho que perdeu
o pai imagine a dificuldade morreu uma
pessoa um ente querido e faz parte mas
quando morrem pessoas tão jovens e numa
proporção 16 pessoas em um minuto e sem
dúvida em uma festa qualquer pessoa e
uma maneira completamente diferente e
foi esse furacão que eu tive que passar
mas aí por um lado veio o outro lado que
vem me socorrer foi a espiritualidade eu
tenho uma fé muito grande em Deus e essa
fé me fez e aproxima muito do certas
desde a minha chegada no Nepal
conhecendo a espiritualidade deles
convivendo estreitamente com o
e durante a caminhada eu vendo é um povo
tão pobre tão simples para vocês têm uma
ideia tá te mando que a capital do Nepal
é não tem sequer iluminação pública na
rua ao chegar em casa te mando no
primeiro dia eu perguntei na recepção do
hotel até que horas eu posso andar nas
ruas para ver um restaurante caminhando
e voltar sem problema e ser a hora que
você quiser ele ficou mais o aspecto de
segurança Qualquer hora eu fiquei
duvidando ainda conversei com meu guia
que há dez anos ele trabalha no Nepal e
eu perguntei que era como é que é andar
na rua até que hora mais segura de fazer
pode andar meia-noite meio-dia duas da
tarde a diferença é que a noite não tem
luminação pública você tem que seguir a
prazos dos carros uma luz outra de uma
casa mas ninguém vai mexer contigo
Ninguém vai querer te assaltar você pode
lá para máquina fotográfica com
smartphone na mão seja o que for ninguém
vai mexer contigo e eu fiquei olhando
quanta espiritualidade na prática porque
muitas vezes
tá baixando um país que as pessoas dizem
que são frequência religião pau mas não
praticante né né gente não criar nessa
categoria não praticante e eu fico
olhando a espiritualidade do Chefe mas
aquilo que eles professam aquilo que
eles dizem de fato eles fazem Então esse
convívio Estreito com eles me deu uma
dimensão completamente diferente e foi
isso desde que eu saí lá de Monsenhor
Tabosa aos 16 anos quando vim morar em
Fortaleza buscando novos horizontes
queria realizar um mundo de sonhos eu
queria conhecer outras culturas
e eu queria conhecer outras pessoas Isso
sim é a maior riqueza que a gente tem é
a maior riqueza que a gente pode
desfrutar é conhecer novas culturas
novos modos de ver gente descobre que a
gente pode a gente tem um poder muito
grande de mudar o mundo não tenha dúvida
que a gente pode é eu escutando os
palestrantes anteriores aqui imaginando
eu também tenho uma certeza quando eu
morava lá no seu Tabosa era molequinho
eu nascer pobre pode ser o destino mas
morrer pobre aqui só preguiça isso eu
não tenho eu vou trabalhar porque eu
quero conhecer o mundo eu quero conhecer
novas culturas Eu quero experimentar
novas coisas e aí desde esse momento que
eu comecei a me interessar por culturas
diferentes e esse ano foi o maior
presente que eu pude receber na vida
apesar da dor que certamente é nem de
longe eu queria passar por uma situação
como essa foi doloroso até para vocês
terem uma ideia gente logo após
avalanche nós passamos por um problema
infinitamente maior que avalanche Qual
foi esse problema
é uma comunidade tão pobre e tão
explorada pelo próprio governo né para
ler eles vivem em condições de miséria
quase que absoluta enquanto o governo
arrecada muitos e muitos milhões quase
senso para escalar o Everest eles vivem
sem escola sem segurança sem saúde
pública Enfim uma estrutura muito pobre
e diante dessa tragédia eles começaram a
cobrar do governo Olha nós precisamos de
escola nós precisamos seguro de vida nós
precisamos de seguro de vida para dar
assistência para as nossas famílias nós
precisamos da escola de montanhismo para
que os nossos filhos continuem
trabalhando no Everest porém de uma
forma profissional E aí nasceu um outro
problema que foi a grande avalanche
entre os ervas de um lado e o governo do
outro e todos os motoristas estrangeiros
estavam espremidos entre os dois porque
nós estávamos lá para escalar o Everest
para realizar um grande sonho mas
naquele momento nós precisamos do Chef
são os guias nativos que tem experiência
que tem expertise governo dizia para
gente
os senhores e senhoras escaladores do
mundo inteiro não sejam bem-vindos ao
Nepal podem escalar o Everest e o chefe
de óleo nós não temos nada contra nenhum
estrangeiro porém nós só vamos continuar
instalar quando o governo atender essa
solicitação mínima Nossa e o governo não
atendia e os servos não cediam com toda
razão mas tinham toda a razão EA
situação se agravou ao ponto de existir
inclusive ameaça de bomba e você sabe
não precisa dizer muito que ali na Ásia
no Oriente Médio quando a gente vai para
aquele lado pessoas não falam fazem
quando faz quando eles falam pode ter
certeza que eles estão prontos para
fazer E aí diante disso nós tivemos
inclusive que um dia sair do campo base
do Everest fugir das preces urgente
diante da ameaça de bomba que ele ser
Olha nós queremos todos estrangeiros
deixa o campo base porque isso aqui vai
explodir a de saber que nós precisamos
ser respeitados não estamos sendo
respeitados E aí foi uma situação muito
complicada
em toda a chave do século estavam sendo
intransigente mas em momento algum eu
acho que eles foram intransigente ele
tem toda razão e o meu lado pessoal que
que eu aprendi também com isso quando
alguém vai fazer uma expedição para o
Everest normalmente a gente contrata uma
empresa e ela é o Americana ou deusa
irlandesa australiana ou europeia de 23
países eu contrato essa empresa que
subir logo a empresa local que contrata
os chefes esses servos não tem nenhuma
ligação trabalhista da empresa original
que me vendeu o pacote muito menos
comigo mas esse chefe está lá para
prestar serviço para mim eu sinto que eu
tenho uma responsabilidade Direta com
essas pessoas que estavam na montanha
porque ele está na montanha porque eu
queria escalar Everest e paguei para que
ele tivesse enviando então uma coisa é
nós temos uma responsabilidade muito
grande sobre eles também então não só
esse uma responsabilidade sobre a aos
escaladores mas nós individualmente cada
escalador tendo a responsabilidade sobre
eles ou seja tudo
o clube está interligado e muitas vezes
a gente não consegue entender isso então
gente para mim foi uma tragédia
gigantesco susto muito grande mas também
ficou um aprendizado muito profundo e no
final de março de 2015 estarei viajando
novamente eu volto pra Everest vou
escalar o Everest mais uma vez pode ter
certeza e para mim ser a oportunidade
que eu tenho que fazer uma homenagem
também a esses chefes Aos três colegas
meus de Akita além dos demais mas
principalmente nos três colegas que
estamos falando comigo é eu tenho
Infinita Gratidão quando as pessoas
virem rosier você teve você conseguiu
Você tem o santo forte eu disse eu não
tenho um santo forte eu tenho um
infinito uma quantidade infinita de
Santos estão rezando por mim ontem
estava Luciano Huck Eu lembro quando ele
perguntou se eu achava que o Santos
fortes muito mais do Campo Santo eu
tenho muito Santos porque eu sei que tem
gente do Brasil inteiro do mundo inteiro
que
Tô vendo que está vibrando está juntando
forças para que a gente consiga isso
então eu sei que a gente não faz nada só
nada de grande a gente faz só a gente
nada há quem diga vou pedir licença que
usou Maurício sair que nem para ser como
a gente é sozinho né então gente nada a
gente consegue fazer de grande sozinho
então eu tenho um time muito grande
trabalhando comigo aqui eu tenho
gratidão imensa mais imensa é não só a
um patrocinador que desembolso algumas
dezenas de milhares de dólares para me
Patrocinar mas eu lembro de cada pessoa
que contribui com projetos éticos que é
o meu sonho é o sonho dela também mas
antes de tudo é o meu sonho esse ano eu
tinha levado uma bandeira era forma que
eu tinha de levar cada uma dessas
pessoas comigo
e no coração e também aqui tem o nome de
todas as pessoas que eu pude lembrar
inclusive da senhora que ficou um
bordado numa camisa a marca do meu
patrocinador alguém que tinha feito um
acabamento numa butila que colocou a
bandeirinha do Brasil o nome de todas
essas pessoas estão aqui esse ano eu vou
ter um desafio um pouquinho maior essa
bandeira duplicou sua bandeira vai o
dobro do tamanho Mas eu não tenho dúvida
nenhuma que nós vamos fazer essa
bandeirinha o nome de todas as pessoas
que eu estou levando também no coração
mas levarei aqui então gente eu agradeço
assim decoração todas as orações São
muito bem-vindas agora a única mensagem
que gostaria de deixar para vocês é cada
um tem o seu próprio sono o meu sonho
não serve para vocês mas as ferramentas
que utilizo para realizar os meus sonhos
essas
e são universais serve para todas as
pessoas portanto gente Invista no som de
vocês por maior que seja ele é possível
a gente realizar e nós vamos chegar lá
no cume do Everest
bom obrigado
E aí